and over 300 Page first draft written
before the lead actor's untimely passing
what changes to the storyline for
Marvel's latest superhero flick had to
be made what elements of the final film
were there the whole time keep watching
to find out black panther wakanda
forever debuted in theaters to wrap the
Marvel Cinematic universe's exciting and
inclusive phase four the latest
installment also pays tribute to
Chadwick Boseman who tragically died on
August 28 2020 from colon cancer because
of this tragedy the sequel underwent
several changes after the first
record-breaking black panther film
writer and director Ryan coogler has
been open about the moving process
behind developing the highly anticipated
sequel he and his fellow castmates took
ample time to grieve and rework wakanda
forever before the official release this
unimaginable loss is reflected in the
film's final form that honors the
outstanding actor and his legacy as the
Black Panther the film passes the mantle
of the iconic hero in a surprising and
refreshing way the nation of wakanda
finds itself both in morning and and
under attack in an enthralling film
bursting with action and heartwarming
character moments As coogler Told
various news outlets the final script
for the Black Panther sequel has a
similar Foundation to the original
featuring Bozeman however after his
untimely death a few alterations had to
be made coogler and co-writer Joe Robert
Cole took a different approach with the
first iteration of black panther 2 by
having t'challa grappling with his own
grief when Thanos snaps away half of the
universe in Avengers Infinity War
t'challa's black panther is one of many
devastating disappearances his absence
left wakanda's Throne empty for five
years which the sequel's original plans
directly address coogler told inverse
the tone was going to be similar the
character was going to be grieving the
loss of time you know coming back after
being gone for five years as a man with
so much responsibility to so many coming
back after a forced five years away
that's what the film was tackling he was
grieving time he couldn't get back grief
was a big part of it t'challa's noble
character would have been deeply upset
at this especially after learning shuri
also van finished the wakandan king's
time blipped away also leaves the
reclusive Nation vulnerable to outside
forces that could intrude and attack
seeking their precious and versatile
vibranium without the sacred
heart-shaped herb destroyed in the first
film by killmonger wakanda is unable to
Crown another black panther as the
nation's protector this place is even
more guilt on t'challa when he returns
which Lupita Nyong'o told The Hollywood
Reporter it was a massive movie but also
simultaneously a character study that
delved deeply into his psyche and
situation as Ryan coogler told variety
the original script for the Black
Panther sequel was over 300 Pages he
also heartbreakingly shared that
Chadwick Boseman never read the next
adventure due to his life-threatening
illness if he had been able to
experience such an opportunity he would
have enjoyed the inevitable showdown
between the Black Panther and Neymar
Angela Bassett who plays t'challa's
mother and queen of wakanda ramonda
shared with IGN that the script has seen
at least five revisions this process is
an enormous Testament to The crucial
inclusion of The Black Panther's
longtime comic book adversary name or
the Submariner coogler revealed to
inverse that he always intended to
include the Aquatic foe he stated Neymar
quote was always the antagonist and then
continued by sharing there were other
characters for sure that we considered
including Neymar wages war on the nation
of wakanda for revenge over the
invaluable element vibranium flooding
the kingdom in the process coogler
underlined his importance by reiterating
quote Neymar was always there his
actions devastate wakanda in numerous
ways birthing a vengeful New Black
Panther with a powerful storyline
layered in nuance and depth
foreign